hello everyone before we get to the
video I would just like to thank
everyone for joining my for our stream
yesterday I really had really had a good
time and I did have some help from Jana
and DOMA boys so really thanks to both
of you for for joining in on my stream
and all streaming is hard work and again
it was a record with the live viewers
over 700 reviewers and a record in the
participants in the tournament we had
over I believe it's over 330
participants so it was a biggest
tournament so far so thank you all for
that I really enjoyed it I hope you did
as well so that being said let's get to
the game this game was played in 1984 so
Anatoly Karpov is the world champion for
one more year but he is and he's playing
against a great chess player from
Filipino before Wesley so became such a
famous player of Filipino had had
another grandmaster that was crushing
world champions that is a gaining of
Thor or maybe it's Eugenio so I will say
Eugenio but in case it's again you know
pretend I said said that and okay the
eugenio tour is actually a Asia's first
Grandmaster he became a grandmaster in
1974 so ten years before this game was
played he was 22 years old and this
isn't the only time he defeated Karpov
he also beat Karpov eight years before
this game was played in 1976 in Manila
and this game is like like Filipinos
great legacy and I will show this game
as well I will show it tomorrow but for
today I chose this game this was a game
it was played in London and this is the
first time London had such a strong
chess tournament
there were 14 players all 14 were top
dog grandmasters such as a young team
and Viktor Korchnoi Yasser saravana
played Eugenio tor Anatoly Karpov so a
lot of strong players and what's
interesting about this tournament is
that this is one of one of Tours worst
tournaments ever he finished in last
place with five points and car
won the tournament with one whole point
ahead of ahead of everyone else even
losing the game to Eugenio tour so it's
it's quite a quite a lot of the game
this we have Karpov who won first place
in the tour who won last place and
they're playing this wonderful game
where Karpov doesn't doesn't doesn't go
calm yes he usually does but he goes on
a little adventure which doesn't end
well so let's see the game d4 was played
oh yeah and I just want to say that your
Gino tour played the board one for the
Philippines in eighteen World Chess
Olympiad so you know quite a guy d4 we
have nice to have six c4 e6 Knight to c3
and Karpov goes for the nimzo-indian
Bishop to b4 III see 590 g - e to the
Rubinstein variation of the names o sync
after Sunday for ek after sandy for
Karpov castles we have a three and here
black of course can capture the night
and this is how nimzowitsch always
thought that the names of each defense
should be played you capture the night B
captures on c3 and then you somehow
provoke white to push d5 and create a
nice outpost for your knight on c5 but
after a three carpel goes for Bishop to
e7 Tour plays d5 we had eight chapters
on d5 see after Sun b5 and now white is
threatening d6 to capture that Bishop on
e7 so I move like rook to e8 could
definitely have been played so the
bishop has an escape square on f8 but
carpel goes again for Bishop to c5 so
already a lot of moves for this dark
square Bishop b4 attacking the bishop on
c5 now Bishop to b6 and like I said
carpet fight so many moves with this
Bishop that tour really wants it out of
the way and Knight to a4 he wants to he
wants to destroy the strong Bishop and
unfortunately you cannot retreat with
the bishop to c7 because you get to b6
and the bishop has to go back and after
Bishop to be
Knight captures Queen Kathryn Bishop to
e3 tor would get too much development
really achieving nothing
so after Knight to a4 d6 was played and
tor happily captures the dark square
Bishop Knight captures a captures and we
have knocked the g3 rook to e8 with
Czech Bishop to e2 and what do we have
here what has Karpov accomplished with
this okay he does have an open file for
his rook on a8 one other thing that we
almost always seen karpova's games he
isolated a pawn and now carpel will
pretty much pull put all his efforts
into capturing this pawn on d5 and there
are a couple of ways to do this well
simply developing would be would be okay
for Karpov Knight B to d7 or maybe even
Knight to a six followed by Knight to c7
to pile up on the d5 pawn that way
because if white white can't really
exchange the bishop for the night even
if he could he probably wouldn't give it
up the bishop pair you know but Karpov
decides to go on a little adventure here
with his rook and he goes for the
immediate rook to e5 and okay by playing
Rock tv5 you do win the point there is
no way white can defend the d5 pawn but
there is one problem to this Bishop to
b2 and Karpov thought that okay this
might be okay but this rope will have a
really hard time getting back look after
sandy v Karpov wins the d5 pawn so no
problems there Queen to see one getting
the Queen out of the way and now we have
Knight to c6 we have a king side castle
by tor the problem with Bishop to f3 you
can't immediately go for the rook is
nice the e5 and now you can't capture
the rook because you get Knight to d3
trick for King the king and queen you
either have the castle and allow this
knight to capture the bishop down the
rope will be perfectly fine on d5 or the
other option would be to play Bishop to
e2 so you just wasted a move and Karpov
improved his position so instead after
Knight to c6 toward castled Knight to e5
Karpov is not allowing Bishop to f3 we
have Queen to e3 Bishop to e6 and now h3
not allowing any Knight g4 ideas b5
create kind of creating an outpost for
the night and c4 and also if the knight
on e5 moves Bishop to c4 will not be an
idea for tor rook a to c1 putting a row
kana and that beautiful open C file
Bishop to d7 rook F to e 1r up to c8 now
do you know confront the rook on c1 rook
captures on c8 Queen captures on c8 and
f4 and this is a this is where Karpov
has to be really careful like I said he
did create an outpost for his knight on
c4 but instead in this position Karpov
played Knight to g6 so let's just check
this out what happens if Knight to c4 if
not to see for this would go into a into
a pretty long but a pre forced line if
Knight to c4 then Bishop captures big
captures Bishop captures on f6
and now not immediately recapturing the
bishop but first rope to d3 improving
the position of the black rook also
attacking the knight if the Queen moves
so Queen to f2 defending the knight and
now G characters on f6 but here black
has some problems he does have a strong
past C pawn but he will never get to
push it and night to h5 now with threats
of Knight captures on f6 so after a move
like f5 you get Queen to h4 and now
there are a lot of threats for example
Queen to g5 followed by checkmate and g7
you don't have to stop this
h6 but now you get rook to e7 now the
thread is Knight to f6 check winning the
bishop so after you stop this for
example Bishop to c6 you get Queen to f6
with threats of Queen g7 checkmate only
move to stop this Queen to f8 and now
the move that if if
Karpov didn't go 494 I have to assume
that he saw this move for toward b5
this b5 is destroying all of all of
life's defenses Bishop captures on b5
now rook captures rook captures on b7
and the problem is you don't really have
a good square for the bishop if you play
something like like Bishop to c6 for
example attacking the rook you get wrote
to b8 and white wins the game
rook cannot be captured as Queen Queen
to g7 is checkmate even if you walk with
the bishop simply rook captures Bishop
you're attacking here and this would be
pretty terrible for black so after this
rook captures on b7 you have to play
immediately bishop - eh
but now rook to b8 the threat of rook
captures Bishop on e8 is now real now
you have to play rook to d1 you do have
to play roof to d1 stop the King moves
and I would have worked to e 1 to
protect but now to Queen to c3
now the threat is of course nice to have
six and also this comes with a threat of
Queen captures rook anyone rook to e6
and the now now comes the real problem
rook captures you have to capture with
the rook because Queen to g7 checkmate
is still there so rook captures Knight
to f6 check and the King has to go go to
the dark square King goes to h8 and now
Knight captures rook watches up a piece
and white is winning this game easily so
there was a lot to consider
after this f4 move can the night go to
c4 and who knows maybe Karpov so all of
this Knight to g6 by Karpov Bishop
captures on f6 now G captures on f6 and
we have Bishop to f3 and now you can
save the rook unfortunately Queen to see
for the tour captures the rook Bishop
captures we have Queen captures and now
Knight to e4 and this Knight to e4 is
such a beautiful move because it
prepares it prepares something great the
thread of course now is Knight captures
on f6 with with a fork and the king and
the Queen and after King to g7 which was
played in the game
tor tor could have played Queen to c3
this would have been with great
advantage for white but he he goes for
the immediate blow Knight captures an F
six and this is this is very nice couple
probably saw so this move but it's not
like he could have done anything about
it
King captures on f6 and now Queen the c3
check and what do you have here
well there is really no square for the
king other than f5 the problem with King
to f5 is g4 check now only move is King
captors on f4 and Queen to e3 is
checkmate yes
so after Queen to c3 check carpet play
tonight to e5 but now F captures and if
I would check D characters on e5 and
erupt f1 now comes with check came to e6
now Queen to c2 threatening trying to
capture the pawn also Queen to f5 check
is an idea so II for pushing the past
pawn and also not allowing the Queen
into the game
Queen to c3 now by the eugenio
threatening Queen to f6 with checkmate
so this has to be stopped
f5 but now Queen to g7 and now this King
and e6 well just sad
Karpov knows this of course also he's
done the exchange so he will play a
couple more moves you know he is the
world champion so why not Queen to d2
Queen captures on 87 grabbing the pawn
queen - III would check King h2 now
Queen to g5 tour pushes h4 Queen to g4
and now we have Queen to h6 check King
to e5 and now Queen to g5 and the screen
to g5 is a very poisonous move torna
wants to exchange Queens as he's very
confident in his ability to win the same
game it's completely winning for white
and there is a problem if you want to
keep the Queens on the board and play a
move like Queen - E - this loses by
force
Queen to e7 e 7 check threatening to
capture the bishop after Bishop blocks
you get rook captures on f5 and this is
completely winning for white if you move
the King to d4 you lose the bishop and
the game and of course if you capture
the rotation captures you get Queen to
g5 checkmate a beautiful idea of my tour
so after Queen to g5 carpel saudis he
except the Queen trade queen caption g5h
capture son g5 III Karpov pushes his
past pawn now g6 at all responds with
pushing a passed pawn of its own King to
f6 King to g3 Bishop to e6 came to a 4e
to rook e1 now Bishop to c4 protecting
that e to rook but g7 King has to
capture can capture Sun g7 now King
captures on f5
well this move wasn't played Karpov just
captured the pawn and then he resigned
the game and because after King chapters
on f5 there's really nothing for black
to do here the the winning the winning
idea is very simple here you just bring
the King all the way to f2 for example
so the King has to guard e1 square and
then the rook is free to enter the game
and he's easily win it win the b7 pawn
and then push push the Jeep on also
there are some ideas with pushing a for
to break to break this protection of the
bishop on c4
so this carpel knows this of course and
he resigns the game so yeah that's the
game
Karpov vs tour Karpov won the tournament
at Oregon last place but a tour also
defeated the great Karpov so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it like I
said tomorrow i will show you his more
famous game played in 1976 in manila and
I would like to thank Dave Pierce Faisal
I'll say John and Armendariz for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and once
again III thank you all for joining my
stream yesterday it was it was quite
quite the experience I really enjoyed it
and hope to do some more tournaments
very soon I think all for watching and I
will see you soon